you want to talk about how we could have
prevented the horror that played out
across the street
look the killer entered here the same
way the killer entered in santa fe
through a back door an unlocked back
door
i sat down at round tables with the
families from santa fe we talked about
what we need to do to harden schools
including not having unlocked
back doors including not having unlocked
doors to classroom having one door that
goes in and out of the school having
armed police officers at that one door
this is not news of course ted cruz is a
[ __ ] coward and greg abbott and the
rest of the gop with him and again like
i said yesterday that has to be our one
issue folks you are now one issue voters
and that's [ __ ] the gop [ __ ] them that's
your that's your [ __ ] one issue they
want guns to have more rights than the
uterus they want to ban back doors he
wants he wants to ban
back doors that's his solution to
children being slaughtered in schools
ghouls are already [ __ ] locking their
back doors they're creating entire
entrances just because of guns not
because of people the [ __ ] gun it's
the gun you [ __ ] dummy they build
entire entrances on schools to make sure
that a gun doesn't get past a certain
door and ted cruz and they lock the back
doors they lock them [ __ ] they take the
handles off of them at my daughter's
school there are no handles on the
outside of the back doors no handles not
a goddamn handle you couldn't open that
door if you wanted to unless you propped
it open like happens it happens oh if
you just lock back doors children won't
get shot you know after going in and out
of the school that's never happened
before ever in the history of ever ever
ted cruz is a [ __ ] coward and he's
not a dumb [ __ ] i mean i wish i could
call him a dumb [ __ ] and most the time
when he does say some of this [ __ ] it
sounds like he's a dumb [ __ ] but it's
because he's a god damn coward and he
will not stand up for children in texas
he will not stand up for the parents of
those children in texas he will not
stand up for women he won't even stand
up for his own goddamn wife he wouldn't
even stand up for his [ __ ] wife and
we expect this [ __ ] to protect
our children get the [ __ ] out of here
with that backdoor [ __ ] same guy wanted
to ban dildos in texas banned dildos and
women's healthcare and backdoors what in
the actual [ __ ] are you talking about
you coward ass [ __ ] you punk ass
[ __ ] ted cruz and yesterday during the
nra presser because that's what it was
folks where greg abbott and lieutenant
governor dan patrick and the mayor of
uvalde and ted cruz at the nra presser
ted cruz is very nervous very [ __ ]
nervous when bet o'rourke starts telling
them to do their [ __ ] job do your
[ __ ] job [ __ ] you're not here to
protect the gun lobby you're not here to
protect the gun manufacturers you're
here to work for the [ __ ]
people and that mayor of uvalde oh [ __ ]
you talk about vote that [ __ ]
out you don't mean to be doing politics
in this forum it is political
[ __ ] and we're gonna politic
all over your goddamn ass democrats need
to grow some [ __ ] nuts here just like
beto had yesterday it's enough of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] we're like oh well
we can't we can't oh we got a soft hand
we got a light glove [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's
politics [ __ ] we're gonna politick all
up and down this [ __ ] nation all up
and down your [ __ ] asses it's enough
of this [ __ ] i'm tired of hearing about
children in schools people in grocery
stores parishioners and churches
children on the street being killed by
[ __ ] guns it's the gun you dumb
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
back doors get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] they're locking the back doors
already crews you should be so [ __ ]
embarrassed that you should buy a
[ __ ] another plane ticket to cancun
and [ __ ] stay there you piece of
[ __ ] trash